Shazam's boy-turned-super-dude Billy Batson
is a much-needed bolt of bright, cheerful
lightning for the normally dark-and-brooding
DCEU.
In addition to being a great movie, the film
was also filled with nerdy Easter eggs for
longtime comic book fans.
Here are some of the small details we noticed
in Shazam!
Spoilers ahead!
While Shazam may be synonymous with DC Comics
today, the Big Red Cheese was originally published
by Fawcett Comics, beginning in 1939.
Back then, he was known as Captain Marvel...
"No it's not!
That's not my name!"
...but that's a whole other story.
His 1939 birthday makes him just slightly
younger than Superman, but those few months
would have a huge impact.
In 1941, DC launched a campaign against Fawcett
to get them to stop publishing Captain Marvel,
alleging that he was just a copy of Superman.
During the prolonged legal battle, which lasted
until 1953, DC even creatively "borrowed"
some story aspects from Captain Marvel, including
his power to fly, rather than just leap tall
buildings, and his bald-headed arch-nemesis.
The court decided in favor of DC, an outcome
that crippled Fawcett.
Later, in 1972, DC bought the rights to a
number of Fawcett characters that they were
no longer allowed to use, including Captain
Marvel.
But there seems to be no lingering hate between
DC and what was once Fawcett Comics, as DC
drops a pretty bold tribute to Shazam's true
origins.
Plastered across the lunchroom wall is the
name of Billy's alma mater: Fawcett Central.
That wasn't the last name drop that the movie
had in store, though.
When Billy's foster family finds the real
names of Billy's parents, his father is simply
identified as "C.C.
Batson", a very clear reference to Shazam's
original co-creator, C.C.
Beck.
Shazam fans probably recognized Mr. Mind imprisoned
in a glass dome as Sivana entered the Rock
of Eternity, even before the film's mid-credits
scene gave the little worm a full reveal.
That character is called Mr. Mind, and he's
a squirmy little worm with a very weird backstory.
He's from outer space, he's friends with Nazis,
and runs a Monster Society.
Sometimes, he can even eat dimensions.
After Sivana returns to the Rock of Eternity
as an adult and defeats the Wizard Shazam,
he not only lets the seven deadly enemies
of man escape, but Mr. Mind also breaks out…
setting up the weirdest mid-credits scene
of all time.
Young Billy Batson is separated from his teenage
mother after she fails to win him a stuffed
tiger at a carnival.
Later on, Shazam hands a tiger doll to a terrified
young girl to calm her.
There are tigers on Shazam's costume.
So, what's up with all these tigers?
As always, there's a reason rooted in comics:
one of Billy's best friends is a talking tiger.
Obviously.
That tiger, Mr. Tawky Tawny, first appeared
in 1947's Captain Marvel Adventures #79, where
it was revealed that he's just an ordinary
tiger who really, really wanted to wear clothes
and eat ice cream after consuming a brain-energizing
serum.
Why does he need his fancy brain potion?
To defend himself against a murder he'd been
accused of, of course!
It's all... weird.
Tawny hops on a boat and shows up in the city,
where everyone is terrified of free-roaming
tigers, even when they politely ask questions.
All is resolved, however, when Captain Marvel
secures Tawny a job as a museum guide.
All's well that ends well, and Tawny is given
a place among the Marvel family.
If we already have talking worms, talking
tigers can't be that far behind.
And speaking of talking animals....
Somewhere on the Rock of Eternity, there's
a giant cavern full of doors to different
worlds.
One door in particular opens up to crocodiles
playing poker, and they aren't just an invention
for the movie.
The Crocodile Men from the planet Punkus first
showed up in the early days of Captain Marvel
Adventures, and have names like Sylvester,
Herkimer, and Jorrk, working alongside Mr.
Mind and his Monster Society of Evil.
Much later, in 2006, a talking croc named
Sobek shows up, and a few weeks later longtime
Shazam villain Black Adam tears him apart
and makes boots out of his skin.
So, no matter how you look at it, those card
shark crocs were actually kind of a big deal…
and they'll probably be back for more.
Even though Dr. Sivana and Mr. Mind are some
of Shazam's most memorable foes, there's one
that's even more notable: Black Adam.
DC announced Black Adam's solo movie in January
of 2017, and it was even supposed to show
up before Shazam! — so what gives?
The Wizard Shazam mentions in the film that
he had a previous champion who'd betrayed
him, and there's little doubt that he's referring
to Black Adam.
In the original comic books, Black Adam is
given the powers of the six ancient gods,
but uses them selfishly, so the Wizard banishes
Black Adam to outer space.
Adam spends 5000 years trying to make it back
to Earth, and when he does, he jealously terrorizes
Billy Batson for many more decades.
So, even though we're set up for a Mr. Mind
/ Sivana team up in Shazam!
2, it's a good bet that the Wizard's old champion
will be showing up for a fight, too.
Shazam! has been described as "Superman meets
Big", and that comparison couldn't possibly
be more appropriate, especially after seeing
one specific scene in the movie.
While Tom Hanks and Robert Loggia may enjoy
a charming duet in the middle of FAO Schwartz
on a king-sized floor piano in Big, Shazam!
gives its own spin on the scene during the
shopping mall battle between Shazam and Sivana.
While they don't quite make the same beautiful
music together, the colossal piano they wind
up fighting on drives the connection home.
And if you're looking for truly vintage references,
look no further than the iconic cover of 1945's
Superman #32, where Superman shrugs off lightning
bolts with a casual "It tickles!"
Similar words are spoken by Shazam while bullets
bounce off of him, really bringing home that
this guy is as powerful as the Big Blue Boy
Scout.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
DC movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.